[Musique]
les enfants rousseau à gauche
pas trop ce soir je vais raconter la
dernière histoire du lapin blanc et de
philippines à cornichons à pepita a-data
à juliette pas à nicolas et pimprenelle
ouf mon échelle
qui lui dit tu me dis tu me dis du midi
une visite
au soir la maisonnée
quelle histoire dit la dernière histoire
de philippines et du lapin blanc vous
voulez
un instant je me pose la dégoûter bien
commencé et nous grandissons enchères à
me
[Musique]
cacher sous les arbres au bord de la
rivière les loirs très inquiets à 30
qu'est ce qu'ils attendaient les bébés
noirs qui étaient restés chez philippe
nicolas oui et qui n'avait pas réussi à
grimper le long du mur et elle a alors
lorsqu il le vit revenir ils comprirent
que philippines 1 leurs amis nous aussi
nous aimons bien les animaux mais moi je
n'ai pas d'amis noir jamais cette petite
fille très gentille nous allons lui
faire une surprise
et c'est ainsi qu'un jour philippines
qui jouait dans son jardin avec le lapin
blanc vit arriver le bébé loire qui
portait une jolie fleur de fraisiers
d'un bois
et il était suivi par ses frères et ses
soeurs cinq petits loire qui portaient
chacun un ravissant paniers pleins de
fraise des bois et par le papa loire qui
portait un gros pot de confiture d'ofra
des voix fait par les pattes de maman
loi qu'elle fait ce taux
que la pab l'homme était plus du tout en
colère évidemment si biti biti
il était même très content bellouard
firca doha philippines et au lapin blanc
de tout ce qu'ils avaient apportés à nos
deux amis invitèrent les lois
oui et la confiture aussi et tout le
monde se régale à
la fête continuera et tous les lois
touche joyeux d'enchères avec le lapin
blanc autour de philippines une pelle
ronde et celle ci était de nouveau la
plus heureuse des petites filles rondes
et coquine et elle jouait du tambour
wilshere tata elle jouait du tambour
[Musique]
et voilà l'histoire est terminée
j'ai mis hou dit nous tu nous en
rencontrant d'autrui des nouvelles avec
de nouveaux personnages
nous c'est un secret vous verrez tenue
je vous donne le livre merci mine mais à
présent on lui
de nuit les enfants
oligny dada
pour denis juliette tort
banni les bonnes nuits camarades
[Musique]
le
début du début du début des umap à rolle
mais c'est le lapin blanc maintenant
patron c'est moi nounours
je vous attrape à chocs ou alors en
route gros farceur bonnut les enfants
allez vite vous coucher et fêtes de
bourg
[Musique]
oh